♪ Classical Music ♪
Mitch Kessler my co-host and partner of
fifteen years,
was fired today for sexual misconduct.
(screaming)
Corey: I've only been running the news
division for a month, but...
This is a good time to start grooming
some new people.
Chip, You are the EP. The show is slipping
on your watch.
The only thing keeping us afloat,
is me.
We are doing this my way.
My new Morning Show cohost is
Bradley Jackson.
I think most people wanna trust the person
telling them about the world,
is an honest person.
- Like you.
- Yes.
- Chip. I wanna produce her.
- Why?
We are in the middle of an epic rebirth.
It's kind of exciting.
Glad you're excited.
Did you know about Mitch?
We have someone who could corroborate
network complicity.
You have evidence against the head of this
company.
- Five, four...
- Corey: Stay...
- Julia: Three
- Corey: and fight.
Julia: Two.
- Are we doing this?
- Yeah.
We would like to share some information
about our network.
Bradley: Corporate culture comes from the
top down.
We cannot accept a culture of silence.
- Oh gosh.
- We have to stay together on this.
Okay.
(overlapping chatter)
(sustained beeping sound)
Corey. He asked me to look after you, but
I don't think you need it.
My brother is having a really hard time.
- You need to go now.
- Don't touch... No. No!
I'm on your side always.
I love you.
♪
Maggie Brenner's book is coming out.
There's going to be some damning
information in there. I'm done.
You do hold the network accountable.
Why rope Alex into it?
We risked our careers just to get the
truth out there.
(gasps)
Stella: Alex, you earned a connection to
the women of this country.
I'm here as a result.
You opened a door and you need to walk
through it now.
Fred is planting nasty stories in the
press. We can stop them.
The only thing that moves the needle is an
even more salacious story.
Kyle: You know who's dating Laura
Peterson and Bradley Jackson?
Al: I'm gonna need proof.
Bradley: I don't want my private life
public.
I need you to release a statement. You and
me never happened.
(music intensifies)
Mia. You should look at this.
♪
Mitch Kessler has tragically died.
(music continues to intensify)
I was only put in charge after failure was
certain.
- I'm trying to help.
- Then don't undermine my authority.
I tested positive for Covid.
I'm barely hanging on right now.
The network wants you on the air.
What could be more informative than
watching Alex get through it.
What if she doesn't get through it?
♪
You really think this is about your
television network?
This is a battle for the soul of the
universe!
♪
Stay tuned.